hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play toward the lie
now this is a small game that someone
pointed me out to me made on the Unity
engine and I I really have no idea
because as soon as it was recommended to
me I downloaded it and I guess I started
playing it basically you're trapped in
the cave after cave in and you have to
get out oh boy oh lordy Lou I don't even
remember how I was supposed to um light
my glow sticks which I'm assuming have a
very limited a lifetime in Oh ho-ho
where am I I don't know if there are
monsters but I'm assuming there are
because I'm in a cave and I have a gun
oh ha ha ha ha ha I move quick must be
all that adrenaline pumping back in my
legs rusting towards the crew ha who is
that I got a gun I'm gonna blow you away
ah I heard that oh oh oh my that's my
flare gun
oh ha ha ha I did not know that
oh I hear something I hear some it only
moves when I move aah
oh crap oh my goodness oh my this place
is like gigant ID
holy crap wait what's this ball it's
something there's some here there's some
here wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa
huh go out - oh god I'm gonna make it
I'm gonna make it out
Oh God good I do now this place is huge
I mean this place is friggin huge please
tell me this is the way out okay I might
have overreacted just a little bit there
but good golly Oh God let me out of here
ha ha ha welcome to the light play again
yeah I think I'm gonna give it another
try maybe try to find a monster Oh God
trap to the cave you need to find a
light okay sir you have seven players
one used hahahaha I didn't even realize
it like this gun was you know a flare
gun and not just a gun gun I'm gonna
wander around a bit use all my flares
and um let's see if we can't make
something happen let me just stand in
the darkness for a while
okay alright enough of that soup uh me
not a nike those flares is bright okay
that was my second flare let's just be
careful careful
hmm I'm so pretty
holy crap seriously this place is giant
that was my fourth one I don't know shot
it in the wrong direction it's not like
most other flares
okay it seems like there's only one path
out because this is the same place same
way I went in this cave I know no I did
I know I did and there's a light
ah okay I'm gonna stay here for a bit
okay don't go in like oka okay uh I want
to go I'm out I'm out of John bullit
flares I'm just going to be here in the
darkness in the darkness in the darkness
okay I'm thinking maybe that there isn't
actually a monster okay okay okay oh I
was incredibly atmospheric you know I've
never encountered a setting like that
nor game yet trapped in a cave you know
that's one of the most common phobias
that and being buried alive so I'm
surprised that people haven't played off
of that that was really good for such a
short game I mean I got through it in
three minutes the first time so I mean
still really good try for yourself in
the link in the description below so let
me know what you think and thank you
guys so much for watching and as always
I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
back up